to present the awards for music scoring
we try to line up a pair of musical
personalities who for instance wouldn't
like to sing in the rain with Gene Kelly
or sing in the shower with Angie
Dickinson
mrs. Bacharach didn't your husband get a
nomination for the best song mm-hmm
wrote the look of love I don't blame him
nominated for Best Original Music score
are Lalo Schifrin for Cool Hand Luke
Leslie brickest for dr. Dolittle Richard
Rodney Bennett for far from the madding
crowd Quincy Jones for in cold blood
and Elmer Bernstein for Thoroughly
Modern Millie you open it as you okay
Elmer Bernstein
my dear friend Bobby halfa just
conducted the orchestra play me on and
if he hadn't encouraged me in 1954 when
he was my agent I wouldn't be here
tonight thank you
congratulations over nominated for best
scoring and music adaptation or
treatment our Alfred Newman and Ken
Darby for Camelot Lionel Newman and
Alexander courage for dr. Doolittle
Duvall for guess who's coming to dinner
Andre Previn and Joseph darshan s'en for
Thoroughly Modern Millie and John
Williams for Valley of the dolls okay
your turn gene oh no I insist you don't
have your glass the winner is the
winners are Alfred Newman and Ken Darby
for Camelot
I can't say very much and very grateful
indeed thanks the honor of winning this
award can only be exceeded by the honor
of working with Alfred Newman thank you